a carpenter is using a lathe to shape
the final leg of a handcrafted table a
lathe is this carpentry tool that spins
things around and so it can be used to
make things that are
i guess you could say almost cylindrical
in shape like a a leg for a table or
something like that in order for the leg
to fit it needs to be 150 millimeters
wide allowing for a margin of error of
2.5
millimeters so in an ideal world your
you'd it'd be exactly 150 millimeters
wide but when you manufacture something
you're not going to get that exact
number so this is saying that we can be
two and a half millimeters above or
below that hundred fifty millimeters now
they want us to write an absolute value
inequality that models this relationship
and then find the range of widths that
the table leg can be
so way to think about this let's let w
w be the width
the width of the table leg so if we were
to take the difference between w and 150
what is this this is essentially how
much of an error did we make right if w
is going to be larger than 150 let's say
it's 151 then this difference is going
to be one millimeter we were over by one
millimeter if w is less than 150 it's
going to be a negative number it'll say
w is 149 149 minus 150 it's going to be
negative 1. but we just care about the
absolute margin we don't care if we're
above or below the margin of error says
we can be two and a half above or below
so we just really care about the
absolute value of the distance of the
difference between w and 150. this tells
us how much of an error did we make and
we all we care is that error that
absolute error has to be less than
has to be less than
2.5 millimeters and i'm assuming less
than they're saying a margin of error of
2.5 million i guess it could be less
than or equal to we could be exactly two
and a half millimeters off so this is
the first part we have written
we have written an absolute value
inequality that models this relationship
and i really want you to understand this
all we're saying is look this right here
is the difference between the actual
width of our leg and 150 now we don't
care if it's above or below we just care
about the absolute distance from 150 or
the absolute value of that difference so
we took the absolute value and that
thing the difference between w and 150
that absolute distance has to be less
than two and a half
now we've seen examples of solving this
before this means that this thing has to
be either or x has to be both less than
two and a half and greater than negative
two and a half so let me write this down
so this means
that w minus 150
has to be less than 2.5
and
w minus 150 has to be greater than or
equal to negative 2.5 if the absolute
value of something is less than two and
a half that means its distance from zero
is less than two and a half for
something's distance from zero to be
less than two and a half in the positive
direction has to be less than two and a
half but it also cannot be any more
negative than negative two and a half
and we saw that in the last few videos
so let's solve each of these if we add
150 to both sides of these equations
if you add 150 and we can actually do it
both of them simultaneously let's add
150 on this side too
what do we get
what do we get the left hand side of
this equation just becomes a w these
cancel out is less than or equal to 150
plus 2.5 is 152.5
and then we still have our and and on
this side of the equation this cancels
out we just have a w is greater than or
equal to negative 2.5 plus 150 that is
147.5
so the width of our leg has to be
greater than 147.5
millimeters and less than
152.5 millimeters we could write it like
this the width
has to be less than or equal to
152.5 millimeters
or
it has to be greater than or equal to or
we could say 147.5
millimeters is less than the width and
that's the range and this makes complete
sense because we can only be two and a
half away from 150 this is saying that
the the distance between w and 150 can
only at most be two and a half and you
see this is two and a half less than 150
and this is two and a half more than
150.